hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings that's
right in its la week on first we feast
we had to get Compton legend Grammy
award-winning rapper you can catch them
on the I love nineties tour and you know
how the show works right but you got to
get through ten wings if you don't I
take half your plug at the end
in your cookbook cooking with Coolio
five-star meals at a one-star price
there's 10 books on my office desk and
that's literally one of them and there's
an amazing line that you write where you
go pimpin ain't easy but it's necessary
especially if you want to fully utilize
the power of your kitchen and I've
always wondered what do you mean by pimp
in your kitchen how does one pimp their
kitchen pepper your kitchen is making
sure that your kitchen has everything
that you need in order to be successful
so like a pimp my pimp eyes have a nice
chain a nice suit a Cadillac and some
bad house same thing with a chef you
know you're gonna have all the latest
tools to make yourself relevant in the
kitchen you need some spatulas you need
some spoons you need especially some
spoons you need an ice cream maker you
need a six i stovetop there you go and
then it actually segues rather
poetically into question number two and
you know a lot of rappers are now into
this cooking thing like Action Bronson
has a show 2 Chainz has a cook no here's
the cue how the hell Action Bronson get
a TV show before me I've been cooking
for them for 10 years that's what I'm
saying you're the Godfather of all this
cooking thing I feel I feel slighted
that's all gonna ask you do you feel
like everyone's writing kind of the
Coolio wave Norco Seneca accident action
is actually actually it was a working
chef we believe way became you know
before you made it hip high but no i'ma
say look if I don't give a damn rice on
the show hey can I get a show - but it's
kind of crazy - like even blac Chyna and
Kylie Jenner have like cooking shows and
I like in a cooking show beef back and
forth it's all know it's a make a cook
number three a yuca techo Caribbean
habanero your once quoted and Rolling
Stone is saying that you're one of the
world's 1 million greatest lovers and
I'm not great at math but there's number
seven billion people in the world so
that puts you squarely in the 99.99%
Isle can I get a witness
yes why do you think that you're like
one of the best in the sack in the world
like better than
because I pay attention to detail I have
girth lift and lift
I'll do anything to please my woman and
not be anything as long as it doesn't
involve my butt no no booty fingers yeah
none of that what do you think of the
sauces so away no one to be huh
everybody who comes on the show says
something like that
and it comes back it comes back there's
a lot of folklore around gangster's
paradise and how it sort of came about
well and I read once that it was
recorded at a backyard barbecue
is that true or can you tell me the
origin story behind us a damn lie that's
a damn lie
i'ma actually I went to my managers my
former managers house his name is Paul
Stewart if you don't know who Paul
Stewart is Paul Stewart we got Rohingyas
fresh deal he got farside their first
deal like I said I happen to be on his
house and I was going to sign some
paperwork and pick up a check and I won
past the studio and I heard the music
playing so I want them to the producers
name was Doug and I say yo what's this
he says this is just something I'm
working on
and I said immediate I said yeah I said
no I said his mind it's like that I've
listened Foreman I said as I walk
through the valley of the shadow of
death I take a look at my life and
realized I free started the first hole
first line and I sat down I picked up a
pen and I'll start it right now here's
some real folklore yeah yeah a bargain
just realized I never picked up my pen I
wrote gangsta paradise out like I
already knew it it was a divine
intervention it really is kind of crazy
how that thing all came together I know
I gotta say it like this I didn't even
write guys paradise
OKC Paradise Road Libre how I was an
instrument and it was the song was the
entity and I was it was like this
I wrote itself you know and when you
have a big smash hit like that that's
like an international enormous number
one like of the decade type hit power
it's our money money and the power
minute after minute hour everybody's
ready but I mean it's going on in the
kitchen but I don't know what's on paper
it sounds like a great thing and I know
that it changed your life and it made
you an international superstar and you
want a Grammy and most of what comes out
of that is good but I have to think on
some level maybe like an actor that gets
a role that's so impactful they kind of
become like that less than a curse
that's I was gonna ask in what ways this
is a curse I wonder the people that
really like games paradise that's all
they want to hear the next one up is
pain is good louisiana-style
that's this guy screaming I think that
this is gonna be the last of our sort of
like free throws and then it's gonna get
a little wild after that last cakes is
paradise question I remember your voice
in some displeasure at the time when
Weird Al decided to disprove it I wonder
if you rethought that at all do you
still feel slighted or what do you think
when you look back on that moment in
hindsight it was stupid of me to say
something about them you know doing a
parody in gates of paradise something he
did Michael Jackson he did Prince you
know people who were definitely more
talented than I am okay
I think Prince did say something yeah
but he wasn't very vocal about it like I
was and it just maybe look though
negative stories one of the dumb things
I did I'm willing to admit I did some
stupid this next one is High River rogue
number six on our list
you've made a couple appearances at a
gathering of the Juggalos and from an
outsider looking in that looks like such
a one-of-a-kind music festival
experience I wonder first is it
different than other music festivals and
I have to think that if you've done that
a couple weekends that you have to have
some sort of crazy story out of it
well whoo you have a Juggalo tattoo I
was adopted about it I was adopted by
the Juggalos they're really big into
that family thing a lot of people would
call them the scores of the earth
but I think that they're family-oriented
people it's a lot of them are people who
they don't have family kids that were
adopted or kids that were in the system
or kids that their families were
hardcore on drugs and they didn't give a
damn about them
I put see like this anywhere you go if
you find some if you're a Juggalo if you
find some other Juggalos don't give you
a place to sleep
go feed you know give some money to move
on to your next destination or whatever
whatever you need they'll help you out
they'll get you high you know they'll
get you drunk
you know um if you were if you a guy and
you know maybe you maybe you have had a
woman in a while you know sanded view a
hot bath and yes I'm hot so all right
this one we have pain 100% this is where
the game changes I have to say Coolio
I'm impressed with your composure right
now you really grow I got fit let me go
move it to the hobby maybe it's because
I grew up in the 90s but I always
thought of that MTV scene where they had
not only the VMAs but also the rock and
Jack games as being really a great time
to have the world in the palm of your
hands tell me about it tell me what you
remembered tell me what stands out cuz
you were in a way boy
you were a bricklayer you presented with
Bjork I'm the rock and rock baseball
game I hit up I had a problem to the
infield gonna pop up to the infield and
Ozzie Ozzie Smith already Smith caught
my [ __ ] like this behind his back I was
aware
I was liar it was impressive anyway it
was fun cuz you know I mean Ozzy Ozzy
caught my papa
and I remembers like there's this great
like Getty Images has all these great
like rock and jock pictures and I was
scrolling at one time and it was like
you playing second base with Pamela
Anderson on the bag and I was just like
I just wish something like that existed
now and it just seemed like so much fun
back then I just wish she would have
slid in here first and out you know and
it's all actually okay but I was a good
way to tag her out in the box and he
came on my head yeah it's like where's
the ball Rick oh oh say this is the bomb
beyond insanity hot sauce we're starting
to sweat a little bit
I'm telling the lights God didn't do it
has much blood Coolio Nats ins gunplay
sat in this seat have I seen such
bravado gunplay got right I know that
you were close to Tupac as sort of a
mentor I wonder what sorts of like what
wisdom did you impart on him and maybe
what did he teach you Tupac taught me
that the songs that mean the most to you
can sometimes be your biggest hits since
2/pi passed away I done some dumb stuff
bro that I bet you have to pop ones
alive I would it stings I wouldn't do do
you think that you two helped each other
what do you mean by that well he was
more you know to pocket in Trish from
Naughty by Nature they were like that
bro
then me and trenches like that so I got
to get I got closer to 2 pi by being
around Trish how did you guys connect
like what sorts of things did you bond
over music we talked about music all the
time
talk about rappers we liked or didn't
like we talked about different styles we
liked or didn't like we talked about
old-school artists or artists that came
before us that we liked or didn't like
this one is Mad Dog 357 season 1 was our
hottest sauce now it's our second how to
saw
but you're like completely unbothered so
pretty impressed what bothers you the
most about rapping 2016 biters everybody
want to be like everybody else
as soon as one person come out with a
song undersold as well everybody comes
out with a song like that look how many
people sound like future now and then
you know no disrespect the future but I
bet you two future he's ready to move on
to something else as an artist do you
feel like maybe things are getting stale
like once people start biting you do you
feel like you have to differentiate your
song how does that you have to change
your style what's with Snoop Dogg first
came out we were in the Compton hotel
Compton got a hotel who's here that's
hot
that was hot it kind of time released
too you know like you think you're in
the clear and then it sneaks up and get
you I'll tell you what I got two semi
attendant to my bathroom tonight I'm
gonna need a baby I'm gonna need an
attendant speaking of Compton do you
have any what do you think of Kendrick
would you do like Kendrick what do you
think of Kendrick Kendricks performance
at the Grammys for tears of my heart
well I really did I got them like I
thought I did a great performance at the
Grammys after seeing this performance
I've never feel like myself was mediocre
really I guess what a time my
performance was good with his
performance was something it touched you
there was otherworldly bruh
that's the hot ones difference that's
the hot ones difference so it's kind of
tradition on this last one is we dab
like the last wing
I'll get it's this hot sauce you want to
go first you're my guest Coolio that was
rude of me
whoa that's a crazy move this is the
craziest move possibly in hot ones
history I actually don't even know if
like you'll survive that this is the
Coolio this is on you whatever happens
this is on you this is on you I warned
him against it that is this is in school
yo ah
you
Wow easily the cockiest move I've ever
seen on on ones what's your legacy how
do you want to be remembered Coolio do
you ever think about it mm-hmm not very
often but Desson is hot
ooh so hot I don't know I
you killed the wings all the way through
this game and then to pull that move
hello you get my composure real quick
forget it you're not getting your
composure whoo
thanks for this hat Oh like I'm dying I
just took a job I can't believe you just
dumped out a full paint can gasps oh my
oh
[ __ ] mr. Moore lackest there you go
Oh dick nice to the time okay like I was
saying I just want people to say that
was a real [ __ ]
it was hella cool you might be
remembered for taking that last wing
down I've never seen anything like that
you're more man than I'll ever be and
you made it through I'm very proud I'm
super impressed the floor is yours you
have 30 seconds to plug away I know
you're a busy guy
let everybody know all the projects they
got going on let them know where they
can follow you when you oh hell this one
the floor is yours
hey come here I need you to do this for
me decorate something good right now all
right Coolio calling from the bullpen to
get his plug off a hot ones first we
made it through okay what's one of them
tell them what's going on
check out that I love the nineties tour
with me some pepper
sometimes vanilla ice sometimes Rob bass
sometimes a tour boat uh the new
cookbook was coming soon the second
installment of tequila Coolio we have
new singles being released from Coolio
um I'm gonna do any album they're gonna
do a bunch of string the singles a lot
of videos little cooking so the second
system and cook up all right
I'm better now my bets is sweating and
then before we get you out of here maybe
you could challenge somebody else that
you think should take on the Holland's
challenge stretcher is one I know you
ain't gonna do it but they want you on
the hot ones well go get it Susan's
warning to get meat under level well he
said Lois big fan of the Elevens yeah uh
you know I need me to talk about issues
regarding race in Hollywood and beyond
I mean you're in the interviewer in you
can't even talk I'm off my gig I don't
want you to that's why I do it spilling
in range of a boom boom Nelly that I
love that song and I mean I damn near
crash